Body cam video
just released a few moments ago
was very revealing and disturbing
Yeah, well,
police leadership said it's easy
to tell an officer to run toward gunfire.
It's harder to actually do it.
And that's what we saw
unfold on this body camera. Video.
It's from the perspective
of two of the responding officers,
one of whom is still recovering
in the hospital
in critical condition after being shot.
And this video picks up
after police actually
arrive here as they arrive,
but after those inside
had already been shot,
some of them killed.
A warning to our viewers,
some of what you're about to see
may be considered graphic.
Be
on the job.
New body
camera video shown
for the first time tonight
detailing the moments
police encountered the gunman
at Old National Bank in Louisville.
This shooting
straight to these
when police arrived
just minutes
after the first nine
11, one call went out
almost immediately,
engaging in a gunfight
and eventually
killing the shooter
says federal duty officer was
Officials say the
shooting inside the bank
that only lasted
a minute was still able to take lives
and injure others.
This awful act of violence
at Old National yesterday
has taken another life.
Late yesterday,
we learned that Deanna Eckert passed
she was 57 years old.
She was an employee of Old National Bank
police revealing
the air style
rifle used was purchased
less than a week before the attack.
He purchased the weapon used in this
tragic incident on yesterday
on April the fourth.
He purchased the weapon legally
from one of the local dealerships
here in Louisville.
Authorities continue
to search for a motive.
We're just trying to piece
everything together,
conducting a search
of the gunman's residence,
not yet revealing what was recovered,
but acknowledging a note left
by the shooter warning of his attack.
One of those warnings reported to police.
25 year old white male Connor
Sturgeon, 64.
He's texted a friend,
called a friend with a voicemail.
He's going to kill everyone.
At the bank feeling suicidal.
Now, officials in Louisville
prepare for an evening vigil Wednesday.
We are heartbroken.
We are despondent.
Their message Tuesday was clear.
Responding to these mass shootings
is taking too heavy at all.
It's more than tired. I'm weary.
There's only so many times
you can walk into a room
and tell someone
they're not coming home tomorrow.
And it just breaks your heart
when you hear someone screaming
Mommy or daddy.
It just becomes too hard
And as of now, we still do
have at least three
people still recovering
in the hospital, one
remaining in critical condition
in regards to the video
One of the difficult things
that the deputy police chief described
was that the angle
that the officers were seeing,
because it was dark inside
and light outside,
they actually could not see inside
that lobby.
But the person inside the lobby,
the shooter, could see them
making it incredibly difficult.
But as the deputy police chief outlined,
the most heroic things
that we do
as officers
are shrouded in people's tragedies.
And I think there's no
exception here, Wolf. Certainly not.
All right.
Omar Jimenez, thank you very much.
Joining us now from Louisville,
the mayor, Craig Greenburg.
He was just at that news conference
as well.
Mayor Greenburg,
thank you so much for joining us.
I know you had a chance
to review
this body
camera footage
before it was publicly released.
What stands out to you as you watch
this very disturbing video
Two things stand out well.
First of all, the bravery
and the heroic nature of officers
Will Galloway to run to the scene
knowing that there was a gunman,
not knowing what was behind the glass,
as you just heard,
not being able to see above them
or through the glass.
And they continued even after Officer
Wolfe was shot.
Officer Galloway
remained in a position
where he could take care
of the situation.
And once the officers arrived on scene,
no further
injuries or deaths occurred as a result.
So the officers truly
were able to save lives.
And so I'm very thankful for that.
And secondly,
just a heartbreaking tragedy to see that,
to see some of the other footage
of the victims
that have been
impacted with injuries or worse,
five of our neighbors
who have been killed by this horrific
act of gun violence.
That's really heartbreaking.
We see in this new video, Mayor,
the moment
that police officer Nick
Wilt arrived on the scene,
the situation as he was shot
by the gunman.
Do you have any update,
first of all, on his condition tonight?
he has made
some positive progress,
but he is still in critical condition.
And so the doctors have advised
us and his family
that they're coming
hours and days are absolutely critical
given the shot to the head that he took.
And so we continue to support
and pray for him,
his recovery,
as well as the other victims
who do have some injuries.
And we're here as a community
to support
those families
who have lost loved ones as well.
So I don't have an exact update,
but we'll continue to provide updates
as we get them.
But we're just praying for positive.
Good news for Officer Wilson.
How is your community,
the Louisville community, mayor,
reacting to seeing this video
of how all this unfolded,
especially when so many, including you,
actually lost personal friends
in this killing?
Yeah, I
think first and foremost,
our city is is heartbroken, heartbroken.
Four,
five more lives lost due to gun violence.
And whether
like me,
you do someone
and we're close
friends or family
with someone who was killed
or whether you're just
part of our community,
These five victims should not be dead.
Just like everyone else
who is killed by gun violence
in our city, in our country,
should not be dead.
And so while there is
a spirit of compassion
and a spirit of coming together
and we are going to unite
as a community stronger
than other and shared love and support
for one another.
I'm also hopeful
that we are taking action
because as you heard from the doctor
at the University of Louisville
Hospital earlier on, in your package,
we are weary. We are tired.
We have had enough gun
violence in Louisville.
violence in our country.
And it is time to take action.
And so, as mayor,
I know I will be working
with elected officials,
with members of the public,
with clergy, with anyone
who wants to be a part of the solution.
To take
whatever actions
we can
to encourage our state legislators
to take action to give us more tools
to end gun violence.
Because I know, Mayor, you're calling for
what's called
local autonomy, for your city,
for Louisville
to take action on gun control,
among other measures.
What are the chances
Kentucky state lawmakers
will actually heed your call?
I am hopeful.
I'm hopeful
that with all of the tragedies
we have had across the country
and right here
now, again in our backyard,
that people on all sides of the aisle
are willing to talk
and willing to take action.
I have heard from lawmakers on both sides
of the aisle in our state capitol today
I've had conversations
with several of them,
preliminary conversation.
And we are going to be meeting
in the coming days
to talk about what we can do together.
This is not about Finger-Pointing.
This isn't about blame.
This isn't about politics.
This is about life and death.
And so right now,
I am optimistic
and hopeful
that we can come together
to make progress.
Mayor Craig Greenburg,
thanks very much for joining us.